[Music]
you say you want a revolution well
[Music]
all right all right all right vocal
stylings
of the pill pod revolution
we have a reduced cast today due to
internet technology uh failing us uh so
here with us at the moment and this may
expand
as the hour goes on but here with us at
the moment we have semiotics guys we're
dropping in
for a talk about revolution
we need like a hey a shout out from you
yeah it's on my uh
it's recorded and returning
was a guest may is no longer a guest
is matt mcmanus matt you passed the test
on your first try so uh what do you say
about being a member of the pill pod
i think it's [ __ ] a you know what i
mean i've always felt that i should be
here and in fact
i resented not being part of the crew
originally so really this is an
injustice that's been rectified
well if you couldn't tell from our vocal
rendition at the start of the
cast we are talking about revolution
and how we all want to change the world
through posting
yeah um just to let you inside
what happens in the world of podcasting
we had a
failed podcast last week where
it was two hours in everybody was off
topic
we were going on and on about the
dialectic of recognition
and the historical dialectic and which
which one we should
be focusing on so this is us
reigning everything back in and we're
going to specify
to try to recover material if possible
we just want to talk about
revolution the concept of revolution
what revolution means
and what to do you know in the post
bernie age when everybody had a lot of
hopes thinking
oh the the richest one of the largest
richest nations on earth is
about to elect somebody who resembles
leftist values
so what do we do if we're going to call
ourselves leftists and that's a big
if but we're leaning that way and what
do we do
with the notion of revolution from a
philosophical or critical theory
perspective
given the climate that we are now
uh sitting in and the literal climate
that is deteriorating around us is it
urgent
oh that brings that that reminds me um
i take responsibility
mr white we're all in this together
uh imagine all the people matt you have
like
2 000 twitter followers or something so
i think you should take responsibility
too i will take responsibility for
uh the universal subject and for
abjecting other identities
throughout history beginning in you know
uh
15th to 16th century i'll take it
responsibility for universal
subjects hey listen i already sit there
every single day and i try to look at
guillotines on amazon
but they just don't really meet my style
right they're aesthetically graceless
they're kind of crude and stuff i need
to find one that has a little bit of
panache to go full jacobin
one day it's a little too fancy you lose
the intimacy of really
holding the axe in your hands and
bringing it down well that's it right i
mean
there's this mechanical quality to it
rather like
foucault talked about right it's so
impersonal the guillotine
right you want something that has a
little bit more of a visceral feel to it
like
well i believe the inventor of the
guillotine said
this is the most humane way to kill
someone because it's
basically instantaneous except you can
get a few blinks in before your brain
actually shuts off it's basically
instantaneous
and painless i have no doubt that that's
probably true
so they were trying to make a humane way
of murdering
the aristocracy i mean that's one of the
nice things about being part of the
aristocracy
right even when people decide to murder
you and overthrow the regime you built
there's at least someone there in the
corner being like well we need to do
this in a humane way
they're gentlemen right we can't just
sit there and hack them up we've got to
make sure that it's done in a nice
fashion
and it's a nice fact that you learn in
history class
in grade 11 or 11th grade for our
american listeners but
the inventor of the guillotine was
himself
killed by the guillotine if i remember
correctly isn't that an irony
was that he also gave his name to the
guillotine too
mr guillotine yeah is that true i'm not
sure if that's true
i i find that dubious i find it a
dubious claim
i guess i'm just we're all about dubious
claims here that's all we do i'm just
fantasizing about having a method of
murder named after me
i mean really what's the most important
thing in this situation isn't whether a
train
like a claim is true or false but how
vigorously and aggressively you can
assert it right
so if eric wants to stand by his mr
guillotine claim
and is going to fight for it then maybe
i can be convinced who knows
so this is really what critical theory
and especially
online leftism is about it's asserting
no holds barred
never giving any ground and posting it
on twitter
[ __ ] right yeah
so in the context that we're uh bringing
up here
all right part of it is joking of course
but
uh talking about the way that the online
left
and maybe the non-online left uh
discusses
the concept of revolution because often
i mean this is my personal observation
the revolution is coming any day now and
first it was bernie
now it's the police brutality black
lives matter protests
but the revolution is coming any day now
everybody is about to become aware
of their class position about to achieve
class consciousness
and we just have to cross our fingers
for a few more days until that happens
it's really a
millenni what's that word millennialism
the christian
the messianic age is about to be ushered
in and it always feels like it's right
there
i mean that's my impression i don't know
if you guys have a difference no i think
that's true right i mean um
if you look at a lot of contemporary
theorists of revolution they actually
connoted and
almost exactly those kinds of religious
terms think about somebody like alain
bajir right
alain biju developed this very
sophisticated ontology of reality
predicated on cantorian set theory and
so on and so forth
but when it comes to something like
revolutionary activity describes it as
an event
with a capital e right the same way
heidegger capitalized being right
yeah heidegger capitalized all his nouns
what up with that eh
the event is something that changes the
matrix of being in a very fundamental
way
and you can show fidelity to it or you
can choose to reject it
i mean it's very hard not to interpret
this except as a kind of religious
expression and indeed like uh somebody
like byju often does
draw parallels between himself and the
religious orientation of people like st
paul and so on and so forth so i think
there's a long
history we can talk about here in
critical theory of revolutionaries
thinking about this as a religious
occurrence
and i absolutely i absolutely
um knew that alain badu was going to
come up in this conversation
so because you name dropped him matt now
you have to explain
what his theory of revolution is and we
can go from there
you're an unkind master i have to say
i'm gonna have to [ __ ] revolt against
you and your kind of imperatives at this
point
uh but putting it really simply all
right alain begin
basically believes that reality is
fundamentally incomplete
uh unlike people like kegel are to
certain except plato
uh you could also talk about people like
spinoza right uh we can't talk about
reality
as a concerted whole and for badger this
has anti-conservative consequences
because
conservatives are always trying to
create a society that's
an integrated whole that's efficiently
robust and sufficiently stable
so that things are more or less going to
last the way that they are for an
indefinite period of time
and for budget that's just the wrong way
of looking at reality right
and again he develops this very
complicated ontology based on
set theory critique of hegel and so on
so forth we won't get into that
but long story short right at certain
moments the
ideological concept that there is a
stable hole that we call something like
society
or we call the liberal democratic order
is going to be revealed as
a incomplete inconsistent
ontological failure and there'll be
something like revolutionary activity
and in those kind of instances you have
several different ways of reacting to it
uh and one of the most important for
somebody like amazia is showing fidelity
to the event that ruptures the false
totality of being
right uh and he says there are a few
instances where this has occurred
throughout history
the french revolution the russian
revolution the maoist revolution and so
on and so forth
and in each of these instances there was
really no going back to the way things
were
before uh not just because our thoughts
had changed about things
because the reality around us had
changed
i can't believe that's your simple
version of it i think i can be much more
simple
go ahead you have a status quo you have
a group of people
or a group of ideas that are uncounted
in the status quo
such that it seems impossible for those
ideas to ever have an effect
in the world then at some point almost
inexplicable
almost inexplicably but because of
material conditions
suddenly that impossible idea becomes
possible and you have a revolution
i think that's actually really well put
and again and a lot of us work on saint
paul
for example right he makes it this kind
of connection really explicit right that
which has been denied before
in the name of the one uh is
now being resurrected or rejuvenated uh
as what stands against the one right and
disrupts the kind of holism
that's being presented uh and you know
he says this is very much a christian
kind of gesture
though of course he's not a christian
right and just to get
uh put it into context the idea of
uttering the statement black lives
matter
implies black lives have not mattered
until now so the moment of the now
when this is suddenly a movement that
has gained
large popular support it was not
conceivable
in the same way before black lives
matter became
an event with a capital e could you call
black light i i don't want to get into
debate over whether or not that's an
event or not
but that's the kind of thing that i do
is talking about that something that can
seem
impossible at one time ruptures into
reality and becomes
possible and i think actually
articulated this really well
uh just the other day with michael
brooks right so one of the things
chomsky said is look like
if you look at martin luther king and
the degree of support that
the american public and the world public
showed to him in the 1950s and 1960s it
was extremely slender right
if you look at the amount of support
people are showing towards black lives
matter
and toward protests and particularly
towards protests in the time of covid19
right it's tremendous right you can't
compare the degree of support people
showed a black lives matter at this
point
to what martin luther king enjoyed in
the 1960s or the 1950s right even the
black lives matter protests
just a few years ago nearly with the
same
support but once you can associate it
with this image
obviously someone dying brutally on
camera
um then it almost makes that event
possible just by that image oh yeah
absolutely i mean there's no doubt that
george floyd has changed the world
in certain fundamental ways and what's
really
fascinating about this is exactly what
you said right i remember
just five years ago right black lives
matter was considered a peripheral
movement mainstream media rejected what
they had to say
or they considered them radicals and now
you have people on cnn sitting there not
only defending
black lives matter but treating this
like it's just a commonsensical kind of
reaction
uh to the brutal claiming of an innocent
person right
and that's a huge change right uh
whether it's revolutionary
that's something we can talk about uh
but it's definitely dramatic
and visceral there's some uh
there's some echoes uh with the rodney
king beatings
and the la riots going on here too uh
most millennials are probably a little
too young to remember any of that stuff
but there's a clear there's a clear
connection
because uh the rodney king beatings
uh were some i think it was the first uh
sort of violent crime police brutality
to be uh
caught on video and and sort of go viral
and and uh really outrage people on on a
scale
that we haven't seen before so in many
ways today's
repeating that event i guess you could
say
well i think a lot of people would say
that they hope it doesn't repeat that
event because the thing about rodney
king is
people got angry for a little while and
there was like the requisite sympathy
and people saying yeah we feel bad but
and then
nothing fundamental really changed right
and i think the question we have to ask
ourselves is whether this is a moment
where
there is going to be genuine ontological
or structural change right is this going
to be the moment where
the system finally has a test that is
unable to
complete right yeah well every every
moment
is an incomplete revolution right we're
we've
we're doing our best to keep momentum
going on these things and
it's this confluence of uh kovid
and the graphic videos of police
brutality
donald trump being in the white house
economic uncertainty and instability all
these things are coming together
or even the anti-fascists are sorry the
um critique of anti-far right
no the fact that literally anti-fascism
now is considered a terrorist act
yeah that might have a galvanizing
effect on uh the so-called antifa groups
who are not connected whatsoever
well what do you think about the uh
communist posters
people who post the communism memes
stalin memes
um to them and every
popular uprising no matter what it's
about to them is about
class or should be about class what do
you think about this
being a matter of class
is it first of all or is it co-opting
something very different which is not
unrelated to class it's
it's inextricably linked to class in
terms of
you know the establishment of the
american state and its racial policies
but to what extent are people that are
out there
um waving flags and placards to what
extent is that a class
conscious event i think to a certain
extent inexorably is related to class
right uh
and the thing is like there have been
killings of innocent black people in the
united states before right
and each of them was horrible and each
of them was awful and
deserved people rising up against it but
no one did
and i think when you see the combination
of something like kobit 19 really
exposing the limitations of the
neoliberal order
combined with frankly just the
frustration that comes with
sitting in your house feeling powerless
knowing that the system is
working to support the people at the top
and not necessarily working to support
the people at the bottom
and then something like this comes along
it's a catalyst
for a lot of that outrage and in fact
what i worry about sometimes
is that the specific racial
discrimination
that was really important initially in
this case
might actually be lost and the upswell
of outrage
that's shown justifiably towards the
system as a whole
right i think the cast that we have
right now is in some sense
maintaining outrage specifically at the
kind of racial injustices that took
place
while also recognizing that these parts
these are part of a bigger
systemic set of problems related to
neoliberal capitalism
i think class is one of the best ways to
slice things up and look at them
because there's so many lenses you can
take right you can take you can take a
gender lens you can take a black and
white racialized lens
you can look at trans folk versus
cisgendered folk
but class to me seems to be the most
explanatory in a lot of situations just
because i think i think
things seem to fall pretty neatly across
class lines
but i mean there's there's also a
problem with getting too attached to a
way of cutting things up like that
you don't just want to look at things
like a class war or
a war between the proletariat the ruling
class but it's definitely a useful lens
and i think that i think that
some of the other ways of looking at
things maybe uh
they don't divide things up correctly
i mean there there are plenty of
feminist men out there but if you take a
if you take a really uh sort of
anti-male
stance you you lose that but when you
when you look at things in terms of
class right it's it's pretty safe to say
that the lower class
is oppressed by the upper class and
that it just seems to me a great way of
slicing things up of course
every situation needs to be treated
differently and we got to be critical of
marxism
even okay i'm trying to uh steer this
conversation a little bit but i don't
know where i'm steering it to
because i don't know the answer to it so
the thing that i'm trying to figure out
is
can you call this an event of class
consciousness
and just for anybody to catch up class
consciousness
is when you're aware of who your
oppressor is
and you're aware that you're stronger
than them because of either numbers or
you know in the sense of the hegelian
dialectic of recognition you realize
like i don't
i don't have to put up with this [ __ ]
the whole
or we have a definite racial dimension
to this
people who want justice people who think
like
this is real or who are only all of a
sudden
realizing that it's real and saying okay
now this is not okay
because i'm aware of it and you have
intermixed in there some sense of class
consciousness saying you know this whole
order this whole system is not okay
or is it an anger directed specifically
at this
individual video and saying racial
injustice like this is not
i would say actually it is a moment of
class consciousness and the reason is
that
as mark fisher pointed out really
elegantly in his book capitalist realism
right
uh one of the kind of insistent features
of the neoliberal racist order that
we inhabited for a very long time is
that look
more or less the structures of society
are settled uh you can try to improve
your law
personally by reaching the top of the
totem pole in your society
but the fundamental structures of
society
aren't to be challenged and he
articulated this very well by saying you
know
people insisted in the 1990s that
history had come to an end there were no
longer any kind of big struggles
that people could engage in because
everything had been settled in favor of
neoliberal capitalism
and what we're seeing right now in some
sense isn't class consciousness in the
classical marxist sense
uh but a sense that the people have the
power to
change society in a fundamental way
um and they want to change it in a more
racially egalitarian dimension
but i also suspect as you pointed out
that in the long run
this is also going to take on a very
clear class dimension uh when people
realize that
you can't dissociate the oppression of
african-americans
from the oppression of the capitalist
system and they're going to want
far more dramatic changes at least
that's what i hope
right and what this really constitutes
for me
as a resurgence of the idea that we live
in
in a historical epoch we can change
history we can
transform our society and this is
something that we need to do
now not tomorrow but
i'm not sure class is ever going to be a
basis
for uh any kind of common sense of
purpose or consciousness it just seems
like it's too uh it's changing too
quickly i mean
the emerging proletariat in marx's time
is very different from
from the working class of our time and
i mean it as as we go into the digital
age and as things become automated and
as technology begins taking
more and more jobs than they have before
i mean
classes class divisions are shifting so
quickly that
it becomes it becomes outmoded to look
at the world in terms of just
proletariat
factory workers versus the owners of the
means of production
i mean that first that owning group has
really really shrunk
all right right so i'm gonna have to
grill you on that point
because you just said marx is either
wrong or needs to be reconsidered
or marx missed some aspect of his
critique
because that's fundamental the awareness
of your class position
is necessary for revolution in the
marxian sense i think that though we can
reconceive it along the way is that like
fisher and other people are talking
about right
class consciousness doesn't need to
necessarily just be the proletariat
against the bourgeoisie and reliant upon
these 19th century categories right
what it can be and i think eric put it
this really elegantly and so did you
is just this sense that you have numbers
on your side
uh and it is possible to fundamentally
change history for the better to attain
economic and racial justice right and
that might not be a classically marxist
conception of class consciousness
but i think it is a conception of class
consciousness in a more
postmodern 21st century sense of the
word right the notion that
we can change history we can adopt a
kind of meta-narrative approach to the
world where it can be changed in a very
fundamental way
we just need to have a willpower and
recognize our strength in order to do so
yeah now i'm not saying marx is wrong
the
the essence of the way that he analyzes
how history moves it's just
it's just some of the specific
predictions he made haven't come to pass
and that was pretty clear even by the
time lenin and trotsky were writing that
that marx had predicted that that the
revolution would take place in western
europe
among that and really the first
revolution happened
that was based on marxist principles so
we can maintain the essence of what marx
says we can see whether or not his
predictions come to pass
and we can try to take seriously what
marx's revisionists and others have said
after marx
and keep on you know no
no theorist is ever going to have the
last word on how history develops and
how society changes that's just
that's just not possible nobody has that
power to see into the future not even
someone as brilliant
as marx was all right so i'm happy about
this we're adding some nuance to the
sense
of class oh
and this class that we're talking about
i think
i think in this case we could talk about
it as being the perceived
injustice we might call it discontent in
like a
freudian sense even so if we have this
discontent
then we can't specifically think about
this in only economic terms now my one
worry and my one
uh the next thing i want to throw at you
guys is if we have this discontent
and people are burning down target and
burning down wendy's
by the way these are great aesthetic
signs i i love the image of a wendy's
burning
all the ice cream just melting out the
doors but my next
point rick referencing back to marks
would be this is not redistributive
at all redistributive at all
um this is kind of uh
an expression of discontent one that is
good
one that is probably going to lead to
some reforms but it's not redistributive
in the sense of you know dealing with
the
the inequality of wealth yeah
well i would actually like to drop on
your kind of freudian reference there
and talk about
impotent signs of resistance right uh
and i'm not using this in a disparaging
way to
talk about anybody you know who's
actually just protesting and so on and
doesn't expect society to change
and suggestion that's bad i think it
actually might be good but
there are always a
certain set of mechanisms in place in
any given society where people are
allowed to protest sometimes violently
their situation and they're in place to
ensure that
they'll protest them but nothing
fundamental will change gladiators and
like rome
this idea of like give them bread and
circuses and they'll be fine uh or you
can think of something like violent
sports today right
or even something like violent protests
in this case and i think what we really
need to see
in these circumstances is the
transformation of
these kinds of violent energies or these
radical energies
into a more concrete political program
that is very specific about what it
wants to see changed
and i'm we'll juxtapose um what's going
on right now to the occupy wall street
movement
and evoke slave argenia because we say
as it is right because zizek
in 2012 said listen the biggest problem
with the occupy movement
is i would go and talk to these people
and i'd ask what is it that you want
and i'd always just get angry platitudes
right like wow
society needs to change our money should
work for people it shouldn't work for
the elites
and we need something a lot more
concrete than that in order to succeed
this time
right just to go back to one thing you
said you know your speech
pattern and i think your thought process
is very rhizomatic
so it's let's go to the next thing but
when matt is talking about
violent sports gladiatorial games and
freud
what he is discussing is thanatos the
death drive
which freud actually himself didn't
mention but it's a freudian concept that
we crave
almost to witness destruction even our
own
destruction as long as we can manage it
with the
pleasure principle yeah you've been
really into death
is that right right i don't want to put
words in your mouth
right okay so did freud not actually
mention this though i remember in
civilization and his discontents
he did bring out the whole thanatos
principle and stuff
i'm pretty sure he never used the word
thanatos
he used the word eros and the opposite
in the greek pantheon would be thanatos
uh but he didn't mention it it was
called the death
the death tribe anyway okay we can
fact-check me i'm saying it very
assuredly self-assuredly so it must be
right
not my area so we have this beautiful
image this aesthetically lovely image of
a wendy's on fire
because someone got shot there probably
by the police right
i actually didn't check the story
there's something really effective about
an image like that
it is it is beautifully commonplace it
has that that
uncanniness of uh being so familiar yet
there's something off about it too
a broken wendy's or some fast food joint
that's been set on fire
this is what i want to ask you though
eric quick question though like you're
the semiotics effort
like expert what is it that makes an
image powerful because a couple years
ago i remember there was that image of
the little girl
you know in the camps the one who was
separated from her family by trump and
ice and all that kind of stuff
and i thought that was extremely
powerful and extremely tragic
but it didn't really mobilize any
popular uprising people weren't outraged
by the fact this little girl was
treated badly so what is it that makes
an image powerful enough like say george
floyd right like i mean
there's no doubt that seeing him with
like a knee on his neck was powerful
enough to mobilize people to get angry
what's the distinction between a
powerful image and image that gets
people out in the streets
yeah well there's something parallel
with uh with an image and a thought
right
when an image is presented or when a
thought
occurs to somebody right it it fires
neurons in a certain pattern
and it it predisposes you to
then think that way in the future as
well because you develop these patterns
of thinking there's a parallel
there's something parallel between media
and the way that
images travel and ideas and the way that
ideas travel
and for semiotics ideas and thoughts are
really just signs like images
as well and i guess
when you're talking about media theory
as well and photography
and the sort of the the suddenness which
an image can be captured and then spread
like wildfire on social media circuits
nowadays
i mean it it's like one big brain and
we're all hooked together with these
neural networks that
go into our screens and go between
everything and
from a semiotic perspective it's really
interesting the the sort of um
you call it maybe a psychophysical
parallelism
between mind and media yeah
but but just go back to like the
original topic of conversation
right what is it that makes an image
revolutionary versus an image that just
makes people mad
i think is the kind of question i'm
asking you know very simply right
because i mean looking at a little girl
who's been
separated from her family because of ice
makes me mad right
i made a lot of people mad right uh
looking at an image of a little girl
whose body has been
wrapped by napalm in vietnam made a lot
of people mad almost
mad enough to revolt right um but then
you see this image of george floyd with
a knee on his neck
and people are out in the streets and
they're really really [ __ ] mad
right um whether or not this is going to
revolutionary change who knows right you
know
what is it about an image where it hits
a certain threshold and it becomes
enough right to really galvanize people
those um i have a i have a thought about
that and it's a concept that comes from
uh information theory like claude
shannon information theory
and the amount of information that a
message has
is how contrary to expectations
it is so in your vietnam example the
the girl with the her clothes burned
off because of the napalm bombing the pr
campaign
at that time is we have to stop
communism our boys are going over there
to stop communism and this is a very
abstract sort of force of good and evil
right so the thought that's going
through our our public
brain as eric said would be you know
this is all right they're doing a good
thing but then when you see
a little girl with her clothes burned
off from an information
theory perspective this would be
shocking like why
if we're combating evil as the good
people
then how could a little girl have her
clothes burned off
and i think it's the same thing with
george floyd
in the sense that uh we have
a colossus of images of cops
being good you know cops dealing with
criminals
cops that you know they're forced into
the tough decision
in the show right like law and order i
grew up watching that right
yeah and every single one of them you
know there's an evil person
uh who's done committed who's committed
a horrible crime and the cops are the
ones who
saved the world from them right and
pretty much i mean
i don't want to be too crude here with
my reduction but this is white people's
interpretation of cops
like if you talk to members of
communities
black people in the united states
especially
indigenous in canada i expect i expect
that they would be like yo it was always
like this
you're the ones watching law and order
we're the ones being like patted down
stop checked by cops on the street right
so i think
the george floyd image is just like
there's no plausible deniability here
like this is actual cop
behavior and then a lot of people that
would never have an interaction with
cops like that
they're seeing it for the first time and
i think that's what makes it so
arresting
i think that's really smart and yeah i
mean i don't actually have anything to
add to that because
i think it sounds right you know i mean
this is the juxtaposition
between expectations and the kind of
galvanizing material reality of that
image really that makes it
just shocking and upsetting right yeah
there is something
shocking about those images yeah they
they achieve
a emotional intensity and
and the way are especially the way our
culture is so visual today they become
almost like statements in a conversation
and they're extremely emotionally
charged and
in a way it vindicates certain groups of
people right like in the vietnam example
there were anti-war protesters already
and so
people's i guess i guess their their
brains were being wired to look for
anything that was
injust unjust about this war and that
image really just
galvanized that it crossed the threshold
and the synapse happened that injustice
and they become icons or what i i would
rather call them symbols they become
symbols because they become associated
with injustices
of capitalism and justices of of western
democracies and imperialism
and we could go through the list right
it's like the
the girl from the vietnam war the guy
with the gun held to his head
right before he was shot yeah square the
prison photos in iraq
would be nice though i mean to take a
feel
that julian point here i mean think
about the image of jesus on the cross
right i mean
there's a reason this image has
resonated for centuries right you have
somebody who's
a total innocent uh and he's now being
crucified by the state
right and that galvanizes people and it
makes them angry and i suspect that
the power of that kind of imagery is at
least part of the reason why you see
radical leftist maoists like al-anbaji
invoking the tradition to this day right
yeah yeah so i tried to evoke like the
cultural readiness to interpret these
images in a certain way as well
because these images become like uh like
a code and we have the key to decode
them and when we decode them we decode
them in terms of
of the need for radical action the need
for social justice
they become symbols of these movements
so the the content of the image becomes
less important
than the statement that the image makes
symbolically you could say
with with uh marshall mcluhan a canadian
theorist
of media that the the medium is the
message in that case
because the content of the image is not
so
important as what the image then comes
to represent
in an external fashion as well and and
that that emotional intensity
sometimes stays with it though so you
combine the emotional intensity of the
image
with the urgency of the the greater
movement the greater cultural
consciousness that the
image becomes a part of yeah i mean i
had an argument with a conservative
friend of mine right from back into this
civil right and
he said wow you know things weren't as
bad as things
i like are portrayed and you know the
cops aren't always as you know
draconian as they're portrayed and i was
like yeah you know it's
probably partially true but i was like
look if you think about
seminal moments in history where things
really changed and what i pointed to
was the arab spring right in 2011.
the arab spring was initiated by a
random dude who was just upset
that he wasn't allowed to sell his fruit
in the tunis square
and he lit himself on fire at the
injustice of this because he had to pay
a bribe
in order to sell this fruit and
a huge part of the world erupted in
anger
right and it's not because everybody is
sitting there concerned like well you
know
will i be able to sell my fruit in the
square of my city now you know this is
injustice and so forth
but it's because it represented
something that
went beyond what it actually immediately
stood for
right which is i guess what we're all
kind of talking around
about in a roundabout way right which is
how determinate can these kind of images
be
and one of the things i want to ask is
is it possible to over determine this
image
right to give it not too much
significance but to
to kind of lose sight of what actually
happened by
making it the focal point of all kinds
of anxieties and concerns
uh that aren't actually related to
george floyd and his passing
yeah that's definitely a concern i have
a point that i think unites
the entire discussion thus far so we
start with outland
alain badir says these events that come
from zero
they come from a null they seem
accidental
and the point of these are these images
appear to have caused
the entire apparatus to
basically collapse in on itself or you
know the revolutionary
event to have occurred but the point is
that
this was a long time coming we didn't
there was no way of predicting
which image it's going to be or at which
time it's going to be
but the whole point of the george floyd
event
is that it's almost nothing to do with
george floyd it's to
uh the police police being funded
or over funded police having this uh
certain mentality that they do
especially in inner city united states
that the members of the community are
not actually policing the community
they're coming from outside
that police see themselves as you know
heroes that are trying
they're not serving and protecting
they're basically enacting
instruments of discipline on people so
the george floyd event
is not the thing that made all of this
happen all of that other stuff the
material conditions we could call it to
i hate using that word flippantly but
the material conditions is what made
this happen
and this is basically the event that
makes sure or makes everybody
uh if we're going to refer back to what
eric said about this collective brain
that's what makes the
collective brain realize um everything
that's been happening
all along this is what i want to push
back against a bit in a kind of weird
way though because
i'm totally for changing the system in
very dramatic fundamental ways right i
think there should be revolutionary
activity
non-violent revolutionary activity
against the system and so on so forth
but what i worry about right uh is that
the individual george floyd
uh and the kind of hell that he went
through in the moments before he died
will get lost and all the kind of morass
that's going on about this right because
it's very
possible that in these kind of
situations right uh
the initial set of concerns for some
dude who was just going to probably buy
a couple groceries
um and was hassled by the police and you
wanted a better life for his family and
so on
all that gets lost in the kind of grand
set of concerns that come to be
associated with this right so matt
wouldn't wouldn't he have been just
forgotten anyway he never would have
become an individual in the sense that
he's become now
if he hadn't been brutally murdered in
the middle of the street on camera
well well that's what i mean right i
mean i looked at the guy right and
he had a troubled past right like he
spent some time with drugs he was in
jail
he went to church he tried to reform
himself he had a daughter
you know he seemed like a pretty normal
guy in a lot of ways right up and downs
in his life
a couple of problems couple of successes
just trying to make his way
through things right and he certainly
wasn't the kind of person from
everything that i've looked at who
wanted to be the figurehead for a
revolutionary movement and that's fine
you know not everybody needs to be
what i'm saying here is how do we use
like
how do we look at this image as
something that will galvanize a
revolution
without dehumanizing the person who's at
the center of it
and dissociating from their
individuality
and their specific history because i
don't think george floyd should be
forgotten
in this whole thing yeah i mean fine
that's what i'm kind of
concerned about he would have been
dehumanized
he would have been dehumanized he would
have been forgotten
anyway which is but i mean then there's
an irony right where he becomes
basically the figurehead for a movement
that he himself would never have
recognized
which isn't really all that different
from
what what happened to him directly we're
all gonna live in
i mean most of us are going to live and
die with
nobody outside of your immediate family
even giving a [ __ ] in the first place
well
think again think again about the about
the image being a sign right
in the semiotic sense and as soon as as
soon as this george floyd uh
thing broke right we all looked to how
to okay how do we interpret this so we
start looking for authorities we look
for the guy's brother we look for people
in the media to explain what's happening
to us
and we start to uh we start to ask
questions what does this mean what does
this mean and
when we're talking about bedua doesn't
he have this concept of fidelity to an
event
isn't that that's something important
yeah right
this context means faithfulness which
means uh i guess throwing your belief in
something
uh kierkegaard would be the example that
immediately comes to mind
fidelity to an event means believing in
the event not knowing what it will
accomplish
yeah i mean this is all one big event it
seems like like
this racial injustice this coronavirus
this horrible presidency
all of this is is like one event that
and the way to honor the memory is to
maintain fidelity to that event until
the day we die basically
i mean there is always the danger
of losing the specificity right like
even even
nietzsche talks about this in terms of
metaphors and symbols right you always
lose that initial moment that creates
the idea
and the idea then gets detached from its
sensory basis and becomes something like
a symbol detached from any concrete
reality
but it's still meaningful in that way
it's still coded culturally
and so i mean it's almost inevitable
this is the no that exists here it's
the only reason that george floyd
becomes an individual in this event
is because it was caught on camera
because how many people were killed
off camera and then they file it as oh
this person
accidentally stopped breathing because
they had drugs in their system or
whatever it is
it's all the silent the null voices that
have been
uh what do you call abjected from the
whole
system of signs that makes george floyd
this side
no yeah but this is actually one of the
points where i'd actually try to stress
the material reality of his existence
right and the importance of a marxist
approach to this as opposed to a more
postmodern one right because
george floyd wasn't just a sign
uh in you know a world of signs that
happened to be the kind of
right image to galvanize people
uh you know at a given time where a lot
of people felt frustration right he was
a living breathing person
who had a lot of day-to-day concerns
that
all of us can really empathize with and
he had his ups and downs and lives and
so on and so forth
but i think it's important not to forget
that right if we're going to
maintain an ethical core or a moral core
to this kind of enterprise and realize
that what we're trying to do
isn't to just change the system but to
make it better for living breathing
material people
who have a lot of concerns and who are
[ __ ] up by the system
in a way that's very similar to how
george floyd was [ __ ] i think we're
saying the same thing but i'm not sure
my point is that there's thousands of
george floyd's
every year so are you saying oh we
should remember george floyd's hopes and
dreams
like sure okay there's nothing like
there's no harm
in that but the reason that yeah that's
very individualistic to remember the
the man behind the image and i mean i'm
sure
all the people who are close to him are
going to be doing that
but for the rest of them who who don't
know him
and for us who he's really he's really
about got the same status as an idea or
an image for us
something that's sort of unreal or or
hyper real
right right there's no reality behind
the image
and that's what he is for a lot of us
and
as long as we maintain this fidelity to
the event of this solidarity with the
movement
we are in a way doing what we can to
honor him and
i mean it's the danger of becoming a
martyr right you lose the specificity of
your own
existence and you become part of a
greater cause you become a modern day
joan of arc or something like that right
you're made into a martyr and
that's what happens that's almost
inevitable that ideas lose
the specificity where they came from but
they maintain their power
and that initial emotional charge is
what's gonna give it that
extras power to spread and mobilize
people to
go out and make change and take action
right
no i think that's really smart eric i
mean yeah i think
that's that's right i'd like to shift
this in general then because uh
this was sort of the crux that i was
going for with my prodding questions
if we look at a leftist project not just
you know let's go kill billionaires but
let's create
media let's create means of conversation
even to reference one of my own youtube
videos
that i made with uh mikey watson over in
finland
to create a minor vocabulary
which is a delusion term to create a
language
that exists outside of the dominant
structure
and in this sense what you're building
and this this gets really far away from
this individualized
view of what action is
but to have a broad view saying you know
what if we're looking for communism if
we want communism and that would be like
the end goal
that might not happen for 300 years
are you still going to commit to it
knowing that you're going to die
never having seen the thing that you're
hoping for
or is there a purpose to
as we said pay fidelity be faithful to
the idea
of revolution despite the fact that
you're never going to see it occur
well i think the kind of dialectical
point that somebody would make would be
that
you don't necessarily need to achieve
full communism because
you're never actually going to inhabit
that kind of perfect state
right uh it's foolish to expect that
what we're all moving towards is some
kind of end state
and that's what the meaning of history
is right it's not
the end goal it's the process right the
continuous improvement that we make
via our civilization where people become
a little bit more free
able to express their identity able to
reform uh to form
reflective identities that are
recognized by others and so on and so
forth
so what i would say to that is yeah you
know there's no such thing as utopia at
the end of the line because
what we need to try to achieve is the
best possible society that we can at any
given time
and that doesn't mean that you're going
to live in the best possible society
that ever will be
but you should try to live in the best
possible society that
is available to you given the historical
conditions in which you live
and i think that's a more dialectical
kind of point right
i think i think the difference with
communism and say
social democracy or someone who's a is a
liberal
social liberal is is they're both
looking for the same end state
right socialism communism but how they
get there how we get there
and how we maintain that state they have
different ideas about
right like some someone like uh trotsky
who would write that we need what we
need is almost a permanent revolution we
need to put a revolution in place
and it needs to be i mean maybe this
actually echoes with bad u's idea of
maintaining faithfulness to the event to
the revolution it needs to be put in
place and it needs to be maintained
it's not like we just crossed some
threshold into some kind of utopian
society right
and with with liberal socialism it's
it's more of a democratic deliberative
process it's more of a
change through gradual steps and reform
rather than anything as radical as a
as a revolution or an overthrow
or anything like that
i mean anything in this country i don't
mean communism
at all or ever like we're certainly
gonna get there but my sense of it is
that there's not a collectivist
mindset uh pretty much anywhere
that says if this would happen
in 300 years and i take
one inch by making an individual
decision for myself
right now saying i'm going to respond to
this other person
in this way rather than this way because
i think this might happen in 300 years
would that be a good way to think about
revolution
in a very conceptual sense yes but as a
concept
not that you are just your your
your actions now matter
because of your fidelity to the event
that you'll never see occur no i don't
actually think that's a very useful way
of thinking about things and
this is one of the reasons i've
criticized by to a certain extent right
with this kind of
anti-materialist religiosity that
appears in some strands of his work
because
i feel that talking about a
quasi-utopian society that'll appear 300
years from now
isn't a very useful way of talking about
things i actually much prefer
bhaskar sunkara you know the editor of
jacketman's approach to things which is
what we should be talking about is what
will the world look like five minutes
after capitalism ends
right uh and he says well if you want to
know what the world would look like five
minutes after capitalism ends
uh take a look at the nordic states
right now
the social democracies in northern
europe
uh you know we would take that as a kind
of foundation point
uh we would make them a little bit more
democratic uh we
would push egalitarianism a little bit
further uh there would still be major
problems in the world there'd still be
inequities there'd still be capitalist
states that pushed against this
but things would improve for a lot of
people and i think that's a much more
practical and much more useful way of
looking at things
than saying wow 300 years from now your
great-great-great-grandchildren will be
able to benefit from your efforts
right because it's something tangible
and it also relates to real-world
empirical examples that people can look
to and say well if we can achieve sweden
then we can go a little bit beyond
sweden
and maybe by the time that i'm 70 we'll
see not just you know five minutes after
capitalism but 10 minutes after
capitalism
uh and i think that's the right way so
you're totally fine with the incremental
reformist
take on things rather than maybe the
revolutionary state that
badu would talk about in terms of the
event well i don't think that it's
necessarily anti-revolutionary right
because i think there are always going
to be hostile forces
that resist even the slightest change i
mean this is fundamentally what we're
seeing right now with the reactionary
pushback against the globe
and these people are not going to see
power willingly right
it's going to take tremendous amounts of
popular support in order to get them to
give an inch
uh precisely because they've taken a
mile for the last 40 years or so
via neoliberal reforms uh so we're gonna
need major efforts just to get to
sweden denmark norway and canada and the
united states and most of the other
western democracies
right uh to get to five minutes past
capitalism god only knows what we're
going to need to
uh be able so you're for a slow grind
but still
committing to an ultimate end goal of
utopia even if we don't see it
well i think it depends on what you mean
by utopia right i mean i think that
politics isn't everything right and this
is kind of where kierkegaard's
injunction becomes really
like pop like important right i mean you
could have a society where
almost all your material needs are met
where there's no exploitation where the
environment is maintained
in a reasonably uh rational manner
right uh and you can still have problems
with your wife problems with your
girlfriend problems with your boyfriend
whatever it happens to be
because you don't know whether you want
to have kids or not right
is that a utopia well i'd say that it is
in a certain sense because
most people are relieved from the
burdens of necessity that most of human
beings have suffered through
over the course of our history but that
doesn't mean that everyone's happy and
everyone's content right they'll still
be problems
but these are problems that are no
longer the purview of politics or
political economy
or even environmental concerns right and
eric speaking of
environmental concerns what would what
would you think uh
is this a state of constant revolution
or is it a grind or is it fidelity to
an event for you
uh are those my three options uh or
no provide me a third those are the
three that are i think
[Music]
no i mean i don't i don't know if i can
really outline an
option but i can push back and say like
even before i even talk about what we
need to do
with regards to the environment and
ecology and biodiversity and the
and the increasing number of viruses
that we're seeing
revolution is always urgent right any
any moment that there's suffering in the
world is a moment that calls for
a revolution and and i mean if i'm going
to be a good marxist and push back
against you
you uh sort of lazy social liberals who
think we can get there through reform
and incremental change
did you just call him a lazy special
liberal
yeah like you don't want to go ahead and
change things
because no no no but but for
there's a certain urgency right like if
there's going to be a revolution
in the future if we think that's needed
then it's always already needed
now because there is suffering now right
like what about
that example you're talking about if
you're if you're fighting
with your girlfriend about certain
things and the utopian state is to be
not fighting anymore and and
have a kid and be happy well no i want
to say i don't think that's the utopian
state right i think
there's no way of relieving
interpersonal problems
um through political or political
economic change fundamentally right
i think we could actually alleviate a
lot of the concerns that
people have at a personal level um by
creating a more egalitarian society
where people's dignity is respected
everyone has the resources to
lead a rich flourishing life uh the way
that they wish
and where their environment was
respected and so on and so forth
but i think like this is something that
every great novelist is intuited and
other
philosophers interiority have also
talked about people like kierkegaard
um or even sartre and some of his less
marxist moments right
they'll still be personal problems that
we have right
you know if you and your girlfriend want
to have a baby and
or your wife right and you have all the
money in the world to do so but you
don't know whether you're ready to be a
father that's not necessarily something
that's political uh in the sense that
we're talking about it say
we have a future where you know the
genders are equal and so on and so forth
right that's a personal choice that you
have to make
uh and it can be very difficult choice
and it might mean that there's going to
be some unhappiness down the line
if you make the wrong one right matt is
there anything you want to tell us
is there any place for the burning
wendy's because i'm not willing to live
in a world
without that burning wendy's picture
i was looking at it as more of an
analogy like if you're fighting with
your girlfriend and you live in a
building with other people and you're
yelling at each other it's affecting
them that's a little bit like
like the need for revolution right now
is we're all going about our lives happy
that with incremental change while
there's people right now
in in abject poverty suffering there's
people there's child and women slaves
and also men being sold as slaves as
well
like all of that stuff calls for
revolution right now
but we think we can get there sometime
in the future
i mean what's the thing like walter
benjamin the great marxist always says
is that every moment is a window through
which the messiah might come
and save us from history sort of thing
right and that's what we need
every moment has to be that possible
moment where the revolution begins
not later not through definitely not
through democratic political
institutional systems but
from it's i guess you're right saying
maybe it's gonna come from
outside of those things society and
politics
well i'm surprised we made it this far
as a bunch of philosophy
dorks talking about revolution from our
computers but we haven't yet brought up
the
hegelian no no no sorry sorry sorry
freudian slip
the zhizhekian doctrine don't try to
change the world just try to think about
it
i'm paraphrasing and i think i might
have gotten it wrong but
yeah we've changed the world and now
it's time to step back and think
we've changed the world so now sit on
your computers and tweet
about it which harkens back as the
marxist principle uh
we the philosophers has interpreted the
world
now we have to change it now g-jek is
inverting that
i think that's like a false
juxtaposition to actually suggest that
the two are fundamentally different
right
uh and the reason is because
uh here i agree with somebody like
theodore donald right like what we
really need to overcome
uh at this kind of juncture is the
tyranny of reality
right uh or the tyranny of the positive
and the given
uh and that's because a lot of people
out there reactionaries like jordan
peterson
or the people at the national review are
going to insist that this is just the
way that the world is
that's the way it's always been you
can't fundamentally change it right
and i think in order to recognize that
the world is
malleable and can be pushed in a more
just direction exactly like eric was
talking about right
uh we need to realize that
the way things are right now isn't the
way things have to be
and that requires a conscious act before
it generates revolutionary activity
right you need to think that the society
you live in isn't permanent you need to
recognize that the kind of history that
you live in
is lived uh and not just inherited
and it's not an easy thing to do right
uh so i think that there's a fundamental
connection between action and thought
that kind of choose this binary
i'm glad that you said that because i
haven't given my
take on this yet so here it is
unsolicited because we're about at
an hour now um but my thought is
when something like bernie happens or
when something like blm
happens then don't just give your ascent
to it give your body to it if you can
go out but when nothing's happening that
doesn't mean that you don't have to do
anything we don't just sit on our ass
and you know take the black pill wait
for whatever accelerationist
world to appear for us so in the
meantime
do your thinking do your writing do your
creating maybe you create a form
like this podcast for example uh we're
basically
you know filling in the form but
uh maybe better examples youtube videos
youtube videos that are educational
that's not a space
that has been completed yet so maybe
that's something that i can do
uh matt with your writing eric will be
creating a concept you're trying to
unite
ecological criticism with semiotics so
that's my strategy mainly
don't listen to my words look at my body
i mean ultimately
ultimately it sounds really resigned but
at the end of the
novel candide voltaire like kandid's
running around the world trying to
figure out
is this the whole best of all possible
worlds with pangolos
who represents livenets in this context
but he's going everywhere trying to
figure out is this the best of all
possible worlds and he gets so
tired out um just by really horrible
stuff happens to him
all the time his girlfriend is raped his
girlfriend is raped killed i think she
comes back to life at one point
and he's like well it's the best of all
possible worlds so i guess i should be
happy
i should be happy but then the last page
of that book
uh leibniz pangolos says to him
so have i convinced you is this the best
of all possible worlds
and candide says ilfo cult of a le
jardin or something i i need to
i'm just working my garden one must do
his garden
and then pangos says again well is it
the best possible world or not
and kandi says to him one must
do his garden that's it he never he's
not going to reflect
on you know the cosmology of the
universe the ontology of the universe
he's just going to do his own thing so i
think
go do your own thing make something work
with your hands do the heidagarian
dassain handlakite thing just chill out
i must say i i plug my my
appraisal of g-shack i i think i
completely agree
with g-jek i think that i think that
revolutions start with a change in our
perception and the way we see the world
and then it leads to action i mean
capitalism since
since in the industrial revolution we've
basically been in a constant state where
of revolution right down to the little
things
of where whether or not we should
breastfeed our kids right up to the
biggest thing of how to manage a
multi-million
population democracies and we're in a
state of
constant revolution all the time there's
no need to talk about the changing
materials social and economic conditions
because those are always changing we
need to get a handle
on this intellectually and with concepts
and then we need to act we can't i mean
we have
definitely changed the world so much
since mark said the original quote
that i think g-jek is right to turn it
around and
when i think about climate change well
yeah we have changed the climate
of the world and
i don't know about the tyranny of the
real but my definition of the real is
quite conservative i guess it's it's
just whatever
whatever is what it is whether or not we
think about it
that that's really as far as my
definition of the real goes
i don't think there's anything real
outside of thought you're back up in
aristotle there
well yeah i mean i i i'm i in my my
my semiotics it's not important but i
have a certain version of realism that i
look to and
and uh and that's that's it right
and the climate is one of those things
that doesn't give a [ __ ] what we think
about it
yeah of course the world is malleable
but there are many tipping points and
breaking points that don't give a [ __ ]
whether or not we have the best of
intentions when we do what we do those
things are going to change
and not always for the better we have
our social system
set up in certain ways and the way the
climate the earth decides to respond to
what we do
is not going to take into account
whether or not we want
an endless supply of hamburgers and
wendy's soft-serve ice cream it's
not going to care about that it's going
to care about
phosphorus cycles and nitrogen cycles
and fresh water cycles right
it doesn't give a [ __ ] about what we
think of it and that that's basically
as far as my realism goes i don't go
into naive
realism where the world is the way i see
it that's that's actually ideology
that's that's a totally different thing
all right so for final thoughts the
question of the episode
was is revolution
a worthwhile concept and i'm going to
throw it to you matt
uh what do you think based on our
discussion have you learned anything
first of all
i did actually and i'm really happy that
eric reminded me about that giuseppe
point because it's something that i'm
not always as cognizant
of as i should be right the fact that
reality is fundamentally
not hostile but indifferent right it
doesn't care and we need to
appraise ourselves and recognize that
a lot of the conceits that we have right
now are centered around the idea that
we are at the epicenter of creation and
the world must revolve around
us and ontologically the world is going
to work itself out because
otherwise we'd be disappointed and
that's just not the way things are right
uh we're a really weird species that
evolved at a very idiosyncratic time
we were fortunate enough to develop
civilization but it could all
to easily be ruined by our failure to
actually acknowledge the damage that
we're doing to other planets so
thank you that was something i learned
and it's something that i need to be
more attentive to in the future so yeah
big thumbs up there but final thoughts
on revolution
final thoughts on revolution i
absolutely do think that we need a
revolution right now
whether that needs to be a violent
revolution uh i think that really
depends on the context but i think that
globally what we need is a revolution
in our thinking about things to kind of
reference theme
generally where we realize that people
who talk about the end of history or say
that this cannot be done
are invoking a false sense of the world
the world
is not infinitely plastic but very very
open to
recreation and there are huge problems
right now
uh probably more problems than we've
seen in many generations and
we need to have the willpower and the
creativity to deal with these things
by changing things in a
fundamental manner not allowing
ourselves the
luxury of just assuming that they'll
work out as long as we continue on
what is ultimately a barren path and of
course we want to say that thought
matters because that's what we're
trying to get paid for so
even if it even if sitting on our asses
is uh
we'll we'll try to justify no matter
what so you probably shouldn't take our
word on that
um eric any final thoughts are you still
with uh just
dreaming john lennon dreams
no i don't think i would use the uh the
john lennon approach to revolution
uh no i i think i i learned a lot about
about bad uh and also about how to how
to bring my semiotics to politics really
my one of my favorite characters of any
television show i've ever watched
is is britta from community she is
the she is the paradigmatic
revolutionary
completely naive completely clueless
about how the world works but just so
true of heart and genuine in everything
she does
and she's right all the time but nobody
acknowledges her
go out and go back out and watch that
episode uh the one about the meow meow
beans
where uh everyone gets a rating from one
to five you can rate teachers
and the fives come to dominate
everything and then brita
begins the revolution of the ones right
and the ones
take over and reduce all the filthy
fives to oneness
as well and that's one of my favorite
episodes that's what
that's what i'm going to take out of
this and also fidelity to an image
i think is more important than fidelity
to an event because an event
is something that's already passed by
the time it occurs
but an image keeps on moving an image
images think for us as well we can think
with these images too
well the event can be an image concept
an
image concept with a dash between so if
you have been interested in what we're
talking about today
um the book that i was referencing i
hope that matt and i were referencing
the same alan
badier book but it was uh being an event
that's where he does the fourfold right
yeah that one and conditions are
probably where he
lays out his theory of ontology and
revolution along with metapolitics most
clearly all right so
your your reading list today if you're
interested in anything that we've
blabbed on about
again unsolicited would be uh being an
event
and then i guess yeah anything else
and go watch community check out the
meow meow beans episode
watch community season five it's true
you'll
thank us uh once you're done yeah dan is
back for season five
no season five is good season four is
the [ __ ] oh i only got yeah yeah
so i never five and six are beautiful
dan harmon's back in the game and he
does a great job uh anyways guys
uh thanks for the talk go have your uh
party and come constantly reflect upon
revolution yeah yeah yeah
and i would say i would say be careful
of cops but you wasp [ __ ] don't
have to worry about that at all
alright peace signing out
you